[MUSIC PLAYING]
LISA GOREN: So I'm a polar
and frozen landscape artist.
And exclusively I
work in watercolors.
The first thing
that everybody asks
me is, why would you
want to go there?
And the first place I
got to go was Antarctica.
Since I was about 15, I had read
every adventure book around.
This is a small painting I
did of The Endurance trapped
in ice.
I'm a big Shackleton fan.
And I always just have been
fascinated by cold places.
I was raised in New York
City, so there isn't really
a lot of connection, except
for having read these books.
There were no girls on any
of these adventure trips,
certainly no Jews from
Brooklyn, on any of these ships.
And yet, I always knew this
was where I was going to go,
and I was going to do it.
21 years ago I got to go
as a tourist to Antarctica.
It was a two week trip.
People generally ask
how'd you get there?
I took a plane from
Boston to New York,
New York to Argentina, and
then Argentina all the way down
to the tip of Argentina-- so
Buenos Aries the Ushuaia--
and then the boat
ride where that arrow
is from the tip of Argentina
to the Antarctic Peninsula.
That took two days,
that ride, through some
of the roughest waters in the
world, which was very exciting.
The ice ceiling
is something that
is referred to when you talk
about women on Antarctica.
I had a girl ask
me once in a class,
were you the first
woman in Antarctica?
I was like, no.
But actually,
women in Antarctica
were really only
there since the '50s.
And it's still a
small percentage.
What I wanted to see
was the blue, the ice.
This was the most
exciting thing for me.
And does anyone know how that
blue happens, scientists here?
It's the density of the ice.
All other light
waves are trapped.
And the only light
wave that can come out
is the small blue,
the really deep blue.
It's really exciting to
see when you see that.
I started painting
about two years later,
although I knew I always
wanted to paint it.
I don't know why, but
it was in my head.
And so these are some
of the first paintings.
They're fairly realistic.
And I'll show you
the next one, this
is the original
photo on the left
and on the right
is the painting.
You can see the
camera mark there
because I was using
film 21 years ago.
I didn't take them any
pictures, because it was film
and it was expensive.
Those black dots
there are seals.
In general, I try not to
put animals in my paintings
because then you kind of
know exactly where you are.
I like this sense of this
is sort of a mystery.
You can see there's some
pink on top of the ice there.
That's snow algae
that grows on ice.
And so you start to see some of
the colors, which were amazing
there.
This is the first photo you saw,
and that's the original photo
it came from.
You can see the ship
next to the iceberg.
We were trying to get some
sort of shelter from the wind.
And it's actually
quite dangerous
to be next to an
iceberg like that,
because the water below
is warmer than the air.
And so the ice
begins to melt below.
Eventually-- you
know this is the tip
of the iceberg--
eventually the tip
part is heavier than the
bottom part and it flips.
And you don't really know
when that's going to happen.
So it's very dangerous.
You're not supposed to climb
on them or do anything nearby.
But most of the
boats that go there
have underwater
radar at this point.
I decided to start painting.
Why would I think that
I could even do this?
I have no experience
as a painter.
I started painting
essentially 17 years ago,
so that's four years
after I was in Antarctica.
I had some friends--
we were called the bad
girls-- who just really
were super supportive.
They had bought me
watercolors to take with me.
And my kid who would do
anything that I told them to do.
And so here I'm making
him do some canvassing.
So people were optimistic and
thinking that I could do this.
So that was OK.
And I was a parent at home,
so it was a good way for me
to use some of that time.
In Antarctica, the first
thing I would say that
surprised me was how
much color there was.
And this is the color of kelp.
These are paintings
that I made from kelp
that was on the shore.
And there were also bones from
abandoned whaling stations.
We think these were most likely
blue whale bones because that's
the gold standard of
whaling because you
get so much bang for
your harpoon buck.
And there were just bones
littered all over the shore.
The International Whaling
agreement was from 1965, so
these bones are at least--
were at least 50 years
old when I was there,
or 40 years old when I was
there, but they're now older.
And so they will not be eaten.
There are no land
mammals in Antarctica.
And there are no bugs.
So what will eventually
get rid of those is wind.
I started being able to
travel with my family.
I had more subjects
and more confidence.
The one on the left is Iceland
and the one on the right
is Alaska, the
Mendenhall glacier,
for those of you
who've been to Alaska.
As a painter, I
started to really think
about my own style.
And so I began to do more
and more abstract pieces.
And this is one of
the things about not
having animals in my photos--
I mean, my paintings-- is
again, you put a penguin
in a painting, you know where
it is, even if the rest of it
is fairly abstract.
But these are all
based on real photos
of what the real world
that we live in looks like.
The one on the left is
from an aerial photo
of tundra melting in Alaska.
And this is pack
ice in Antarctica.
So you can see it's getting
more and more abstract.
5 and 1/2 years
ago, 6 years ago,
I decided I would apply
for an artist residency.
A lot of my artist friends
were really supportive
and said, oh, you
should try one of those.
And I did apply for
one and didn't get it,
but I got a letter
with it that said,
you should apply for others.
The reason you didn't get it is
because of your financial range
didn't fit what
this residency was.
So I started looking and
there was this residency
at the top of the world.
And I thought, oh,
that looks interesting.
And I did not tell anyone that
I applied for it, because I was
like, I'm not going to get it.
And then I get an email saying,
we're sorry to tell you--
so it's like, OK.
Didn't get it.
But I thought, well,
I should read it
in case they give
me some advice.
And they said, we're
sorry to tell you
you didn't get it this year,
but you're going next year.
So I was like, OK, I guess
I got to tell my husband.
You know, I really
hadn't told anyone.
So I was like, oh my god.
So this is with
the Arctic Circle.
And this is-- we were
sailing on a tall ship
around the island of Svalbard.
Anybody here read
"The Golden Compass?"
That's the island of polar bears
where Iorek Byrnison lives.
We didn't see any
armored polar bears.
But this is 500 miles
from the North Pole.
Just to give you a sense
of how far north it
is, almost too far north
to see the northern lights.
The northern lights are
more available closer
to the Arctic Circle.
To go on a trip like this
where I was gone for a month--
it was two weeks on the
boat, but I was essentially
gone for a month--
as a mom with, at that
time, a 12-year-old kid,
you have to really--
I had to really
spend a lot of time
figuring out what am I going
to do, how am I going to do it?
And so the first thing I
had to do was a Kickstarter.
I had to raise money.
So if you think, six
years ago Kickstarter
was still not as
all over the place.
And I had to explain Kickstarter
as like WGBH fundraiser,
only you'd be
sending me somewhere.
So there were still people
didn't really know about it.
And I was very successful in my
Kickstarter, which was great.
Shopping, I had to do some
shopping for this trip.
Most people asked
what I need to buy.
As a New Englander, I didn't
really need to buy that much.
The weather was pretty much
the same as winter here.
But the organization of an
absence is the big part.
And this is, as an artist,
this isn't really something
that you would
think, oh, you know,
you have to do all these things.
I had to get the dog
sitter for a month.
I had to make sure that my
kid was going to have dinner
every night, you know,
because my husband was home
but he was working.
He had rehearsals.
You know, he has a life, too.
So it's interesting because
when I speak to groups,
I often have mothers
come up to me
and say, how did you do that?
Because it is-- in
retrospect, it was insane.
But I did that.
And it left a mark on my family.
This is my son and
my nephew and me.
We're in Brookline Ice.
I don't know if any of you've
driven past that place.
Brookline Ice is where
all the ice sculptures
for New Year's Eve are stored.
And so they let us do the
video for the Kickstarter
in Brookline Ice.
So that was pretty cool.
The residency itself
had 27 artists--
six men, 21 women.
It was gender neutral when
they do the applications.
They don't know the
names of the people.
So this was the one with
the most amount of women.
There were from 10 countries.
And you can see on the map kind
of all where they were from.
There were all different
types of artists--
painters, spoken word, poetry.
You can read all that.
You can see.
This is a picture of us the
day we started on the ship.
It hadn't snowed
yet in Svalbard.
And then it snowed pretty
consistently after that.
This was in September, so
right before winter sets in.
And then you see
the sign that says
beware throughout Svalbard.
Danger throughout Svalbard.
Svalbard has more polar bears
than people in the winter.
In the summer, there's a
lot of tourists that go by.
This is what the on board
experience looked like.
You have kind of a higher
level part of the galley
and then lower level.
And most people had
laptops of some sort.
And those artists
actually were able to do
a lot of work, the people
who use their laptops,
so that would be
photographers, videographers,
the sound artists.
Those of us who were
painters, dancers, writers, we
couldn't really do a
lot of our work there.
So it was more of a gathering
expedition as opposed to--
it was just not enough space.
My pieces, as you
can see, are large.
So it would take
up the whole table.
It would not be possible.
And of course, the boat's
moving the whole time.
You know, there's no flat time.
The places we slept were below.
So there's our staircase.
We were in bunks.
That's a bunk there.
We called it the nest.
Then, of course, the bar,
which was very important.
And that's part of the galley.
Considering we'd never
met each other before,
we did pretty well together.
We were working when
we were on the ship.
This is someone who had a GoPro
that she put on top of a kite--
because of course, there
weren't drones then.
So this was pre-drone,
first, second year of GoPro.
So we were really avant garde.
And so she was sailing
the kite above and doing
these really cool imaging.
And she was doing a
lot of map projects.
Everybody had their own kind of
work that they were focused on.
And everybody had to
give a presentation
during the evenings.
So each evening there'd
be like three artists.
And this is my roommate
giving a presentation talking
about her dog.
But she is a fantastic artist.
Her work is quilts
made out of wood that
are taken from Hurricane Sandy.
And so she breaks them up
and makes them into quilts.
So really interesting stuff.
She collected garbage that
was on the shore, which
unfortunately there
was quite a lot,
because where we were in
Svalbard was on the route of--
we were from Russia.
We'd get Russian garbage
was where there's
the stream of water came from.
And nets, too.
Every time we got off
the boat, somebody
would take a trip
in that zodiac--
that's the pack ice
right in front of you.
That means the ice
that's breaking there.
We'd take a trip on the zodiac.
And they would go and
they would look and do
a tour of the area that
we were going to be.
And the reason they
needed to do this
was to see if it
was polar bear free.
The dog was a new
addition to the tour.
They had never had a dog before.
I can't tell you
how thrilled I was
that this dog was on
the tour, because I
knew the dog could smell a
bear before we could see it.
I have never felt more
urban than when we
were talking about polar bears.
You can't walk
anywhere in Svalbard
without a guide with a gun.
Get onto shore.
These are the rifles.
They'd gather us all together.
So maybe four or five trips on
this zodiac from the boat once
everything was clear.
Get onto the shore.
We'd get our sort of water gear
off and get our work gear on.
And they'd say, OK,
everybody stand around.
We're loading the guns.
The bullets are this big.
And they said, you don't get
two shots with a polar bear.
No polar bears were hurt.
That's always a big fear.
But they are absolutely
terrifying because, you know,
one shot-- you have to get that
shot right with a polar bear.
So the dog, I stuck
to the dog like glue.
I was like, Nemo is my hero.
So then when we
were there, we were
in this triangulated space,
generally on the shore,
where on each point
of the triangle
would be someone with a gun.
Sometimes we would take hikes.
There would be a guide
at the front with a gun
and a guide at the
back with the gun.
And I would never go on
the hike unless the dog
was going, because the dog
didn't go on every hike.
People would always
say, you're so
brave to have gone
to Antarctica.
That was no fear.
This was fear, but
made it through it.
So here's my feelings
about polar bears.
So this is a polar bear from
the distance, you can see.
He's kind of far off.
We were on the boat.
Whenever we saw the polar
bears, we were on the boat.
That just was how
it worked for us.
I was thrilled about that.
This is a polar bear.
We had just gotten
back on the boat.
The polar bear was sniffing
around where we had just been.
I was like-- everybody's
like, polar bear!
Oh, god.
But I did want to do
some stuff with my art,
as opposed to just fear.
This is arctic ice,
to some extent,
every place you go
with this kind of ice
is going to have different ice.
In the Arctic, the jade ice is
because moss and green things
have been frozen.
And then 10,000 years
later, that's what's left.
So jade ice is--
and then you can see those
sort of brown or red stripes.
That's iron in the soil.
That's called glass ice.
Glass ice occurs when
an iceberg has flipped.
So this is a very recent flipped
iceberg, because you get that--
you have an ice
cube in your water,
the part that's
under water is clear.
The part that's on top
is somewhat oxidized
and has that kind of
white burnished bit.
And that's what happens
when an iceberg flips,
is you get the clear part up.
And you can see it's starting
to turn white at the top.
Those stripes are
due to layers of soot
that came on top
of dirt or whatever
blew onto the
glacier, frozen in,
and then 10,000 years later
that's how you get a stripe.
And that's the beginning
of that on the left
is moss freezing inside of ice,
just right in front of my face.
Obviously, that's not
ready to be an iceberg,
but that's the beginning
of the process.
The next two pictures are
interesting because they're
both taken with color film.
This is within a day or two.
The left you can see
at the very edge,
you can see the
blue a little bit.
There's a color--
it's a color picture
of the crazy
formations in the rock
and the glaciers
areas in Svalbard.
Svalbard is a newer
earth formation
compared to Antarctica.
And so Antarctica
has much, much,
much more in terms
of heavy glaciers
because they're so big.
They've been there
for a long time.
In a way, it's more like
Iceland, up near Svalbard,
which is Iceland being
a volcanic island.
This is just a sunset, you know.
You look for one
minute, it's there,
and the next minute, it's gone.
As we were in September, we
were heading towards October,
the beginning of November,
maybe 10th of November,
there's no more light.
So the days are getting
much, much, much shorter.
You have a sunrise.
Five hours later, sunset.
You never have high noon.
It just is, like, up, down.
And it's always this
really weak light.
You know, it's never
really super sunny.
And when you do
see the sun, you're
just like, oh, there it is.
There was life in the
Arctic, unlike in Antarctica.
You did see penguins
and you'd see birds.
But the Arctic has
a lot of mammals,
as we know from polar bears.
And there's whales.
And these are reindeer.
We were actually on a
hike there with Nemo.
And the reindeer didn't
come anywhere near us.
We had some Canadians
on the trip.
And the Canadians said, if you
hold your hands up like this,
the reindeer have
terrible eyesight,
and they will come to
see if you are reindeer.
And I was like,
this is so stupid.
So there's maybe eight
or 10 of us going--
I'm telling you, they
came right up to us.
It was like, whoa,
here comes a reindeer.
And they were totally fine.
They weren't interested
in us, really.
And then this is
the big city called
Longyearbyen on Svalbard.
And you can see
it's not a big city.
There is a university
there, though.
And there are people who
live there all year round.
There are schools for
kids, because there
are professors and people who
live there all year round.
The children in the schools,
they have a play area.
At the play area they go out in
their very, very bright vests.
Remember that part of the
time they're going out it's
totally dark.
They have lights on their vests.
And there's always
someone with a gun.
They count them coming in.
They count them going--
you know coming out,
they count them going in.
Because you just don't want to
lose a child to a polar bear.
That's a painting of some of
that same earth formation.
To the left, this is an
abandoned whaling station
in the Arctic.
They don't have any buildings
really left in the Arctic.
And that's because,
for the most part,
they're still whaling
in the Arctic.
And they whale on factory ships.
So anything that
would have been there,
would have moved off into
something that they could use.
But this is moss that's
growing in the area that
was a whaling station.
And the moss we weren't
allowed to get close to it.
You could not touch it.
It was about 50
years old this moss,
and it grows on the oil that
is spilt from the whales.
So it's this crazy--
grows tiny, tiny amounts,
so there must just
be tons of it in the soil,
because it grows just
based on that.
There is the painting
of the moss in the ice,
another one of the formation,
and then some of the glaciers.
So then the question is,
what did I learn from it?
What am I doing now?
This is obviously
a picture of me.
One of the things
about being an artist
is you could get a degree,
but it doesn't really
mean you're an artist.
You kind of just
have to say you're
an artist to be an artist.
And that's it.
And then people believe you.
And so, one of the
things on the trip, I
was feeling very self-conscious.
I felt like, well, I haven't
been doing it this long,
and there are people
here whose work
is in museums,
who teach college,
who are retired artists.
I mean, there were some
famous artists on the trip.
And I thought, I should just
kind of keep my mouth shut.
And they were
really encouraging.
And one of the things
they talked about
is permission, permission to
say I'm going to try this.
I'm going to do
something different.
And it doesn't matter,
because I'm an artist,
and I can try and do that.
And it's just sort of
owning that word, which
is the own your artist self.
Practice.
This is something that
pretty much everybody knows,
that you do a little bit
all the time and it adds up.
You have to just keep at it.
And a lot of artists go and
they just work and maybe they're
not doing something
that's focused
on what their show might
be or what they're teaching
or whatever.
But it's just always sort
of fueling that artist head.
And you just have
to keep working.
Small steps add up.
You just do a little
bit all the time.
Walking into your
studio, do a little bit,
walk out, walk back in.
It just does add up.
And I found that
communicating through a blog
and then doing writing was
actually really helpful,
because a lot of putting
your art out there
is about sort of
being able to say,
this is what this package
is, and this is why
you might be interested in it.
A lot of times, I'd say that
artists don't feel comfortable
writing about their work or
talking about their work.
And I obviously don't
have any problem about it,
but that is a really
important part
of being able to share
your work with the world.
There's nobody who's-- or the
person who is being discovered
by Instagram with no
other explanation is rare.
You're going to have to
sort of talk about yourself
a little bit or your work.
So now it's 5 and
1/2 years later
and I'm still processing
what I've learned there.
I'm still a full time mom.
I still have my kid at home,
for another four or five months,
but--
and that is something
to try and balance that.
There's no question
that that's tough.
I have not been able to
travel as much as I wanted.
It was actually a very
difficult thing for my son,
for me to be gone a month.
He had started a new school
and that was the first four
weeks of his new school.
And we really paid for that.
I had to come back and
be not just full time
mom, I had to be 110%
mom, and then maybe I
could do some art on the side.
And you just have to find
which weeks you can do which.
And we didn't get
to travel as much--
I've been to Iceland
since I got back,
but that's the only
place I've been to since.
And so I started
taking photographs
of winters in Boston,
some of the ice formations
here, and doing some
more abstract pieces.
And I'll show you a few of them.
I have new surfaces.
You can see over there
that square piece is
on something called clayboard.
It's actually not
made for watercolor.
Everything I work
on is watercolor.
And that's because I like
to use water to paint water,
and also I really feel
that ecologically, it's
the best paint for me to use.
You don't use a lot.
You don't waste a lot.
And it is dissolvable.
So by using that surface, it
does something very different
than the surface next to it,
which is traditional paper.
So I'm working on
different sizes.
I have some 5 feet
by 5 feet pieces.
And that's unusual
for watercolor.
And this is part of that
whole thing of permission.
I'd just like-- let's try this.
And then I'm just doing small
steps, bits and bits and bits.
A year and a half
after I got back,
I was asked to write an
article for "The New York
Times," for the travel section,
about being on a cruise ship,
because my cruise ship was a
different kind of cruise ship.
And I was amazed to get a full
page in the travel section.
As a New Yorker, my father
opened it and it was--
I had just won the
Oscar, you know.
That was it, to be in
"The New York Times."
But it's a game changer.
People still remember
this article.
They talk to me--
I still get responses from it.
It is still clicked on on
"The New York Times" website.
It's just astonishing.
And so I have a copy of it
there because I milk it for all
it's worth.
But this is my son looking at
me thinking, you are not famous.
But the day, literally the
day that came out on paper--
because it was out online on a
Friday, the Sunday morning it
was out someone
emailed me and bought
one of the paintings
that was in the article.
And here's a funny thing
about being an artist,
the first thing they said is,
will you give me a discount?
And because I didn't
speak to them in person--
I hadn't sold that
much at that point,
and we have always been
told, don't give discounts,
don't give discounts--
because I was not speaking
to them in person, I said no.
And I was like, I just blew it.
Sent the email.
I mean, right back, OK.
And it's funny because
all of a sudden I
was in a different level.
Like, I just didn't
realize that.
But by being in "The
New York Times,"
it's like you get to call
the shots a bit more.
So that was very
exciting for me.
So now here's some photos.
That's top left is a photo
of Spy Pond in Arlington
this year.
In December-- actually,
it was last year--
in December when it was
so cold and the bubbles
had frozen in the pond.
The photo on the
bottom right is a photo
I took while walking the dog.
That's in Stony
Brook reservation.
Just an ice formation
on the ground.
It's amazing to see what you see
with ice in every place that's
different.
So that's near.
This is far.
That's Iceland on the top here.
You have these black
stripes in the ice.
Again, the ice is
different in Iceland,
and that's because
of the volcanoes.
So the ash lands on
the ice, freezes,
and then 10 years later,
20 years later, you know,
it's covered in snow.
And then as it comes off of
the glacier, flips, it goes up,
obviously the volcano didn't
make the stripes that way.
But the iceberg is
flipped on its side.
And then this is just amazing
to be living in this time
where we can see ice on Mars.
That's ice on Mars
from a photo from NASA.
I have sent the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory some of my paintings
and they are rock stars.
They tweeted it all over the
place, which was really cool.
I'm a bit of a NASA geek,
so it was fantastic.
Isn't that amazing
that we can see that?
So that is not my photo.
I've been asked that,
as well, by kids,
if I was the first
woman in Antarctica
and if I took the
pictures of Mars.
So neither of us do.
But those are both
public domain.
Because of NASA, we own those.
The next thing is
the final slide.
And I just-- this is me
swimming in the Arctic.
This is the only
place we could go
where there were no polar bears,
because polar bears can swim.
The dog did the
tour of the beach,
making sure there were no--
but there was a town on one side
and the dock on the other side.
The point was we were
going to go in, take a dip,
and then run back out, wash on
the boat, you know, hot water.
So I went in and I
said, it's like Maine.
It's not bad.
Maine in April, right?
I was in for about a second.
Then I was like,
oh, it's so bad.
I ran out.
My roommate was
right on the beach.
She didn't want to go.
And she wrapped me in a towel.
And ran up to the thing.
And to this day, I
still have a little bit
of frostbite in my fingers
when it's really, really cold.
I always have to wear gloves.
But I encourage you to be
brave, even if it's stupid.
That's it.
So does anybody
have any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Any questions about anything?
AUDIENCE: Have you found
that your perception of color
in your day-to-day life has
changed since your trips
to the Arctic and Antarctic?
LISA GOREN: Yes, definitely,
because I look at color more.
I would say I brought--
because I bought film
to the Antarctic,
I brought a roll
of black and white.
I was going to be all Ansel
Adams, you know, fantastic.
It was the worst roll I
took, because there are so
many colors there.
And it really opened my
eyes to seeing things.
And so now I see a lot,
especially in the winter
here, because I
don't particularly
enjoy the summers here.
Winter is my season.
And people often see the winter
as kind of boring and white
and dead.
And there's just so much color
in the snow and on the ground
and in the leaves and with
the evergreens, obviously.
So I do see more.
I would say it's not so
much about the trip--
although that opened my
eyes to some extent--
it's that I look at color
more as I paint more,
if you think about it that way.
I'd say that may have had
more of an effect on it.
I mean, I do love color.
And I'm glad that there's
color in all the places I love.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: What happens if you
touch the scary whale blubber
moss?
LISA GOREN: Traveling
to these places,
you have to be respectful.
This is not-- there's
nobody who's going to say--
well, I mean, people
who were the tour guides
would have said something.
They said, you
can't go over there.
But you go on to a trip like
this with the understanding
that you respect that
this is part of our planet
that we want to preserve.
If everybody took a piece of
that moss, it would be gone.
And the same is true
with those whale bones.
I was interviewed by a woman
who said, did you take one home?
And I was like,
first of all, do you
understand the size
of a blue whale?
But it's illegal.
You cannot bring that--
I'm not 100% sure
of the actual laws
in terms of bringing pieces of
mammal stuff into the states.
But there's definitely
restrictions. .
And I think anytime you
go to a place that's
a nature preserve,
that's what these are.
You have to act respectful.
We did have one artist who
painted some of the rocks.
And he was really yelled
at by the tour guides.
And they were like,
you have to clean that.
And it's already disturbed then.
So you know, it isn't
a silly question.
It's more about, we're not just
there to put our stamp on it.
Yeah.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Oh, thank
you for the talk.
So, you mentioned the garbage.
Where is this
garbage coming from?
From the sea?
LISA GOREN: The garbage
that was collected was--
there's all sorts of currents.
So wherever the
current comes from
is where the garbage
will flow from.
Because we're so far
north in Svalbard,
we were near the Russian coast.
And I can pull up that map
if you want to see that.
So they were fishing villages up
there and mining camps up there
and boats, cold water fishing.
So there would be nets.
I mean, we found a
sneaker, you know--
and things take a long
time to degrade there,
even longer than when it's hot.
Because when it's hot,
you do have the bugs.
You do have more animals
that would decompose
what you could decompose.
I think the worst part
of it is the nets,
because those are the things
that whales and other mammals
that need to breathe in the
water-- and fish in general--
they get caught.
And that's sad and horrible.
But it was coming from Russia,
from that kind of thing.
Some days we didn't see any.
But if you think about
even the coast here,
we get currents from the north.
They come down.
So we get garbage from there.
Yeah.
OK, no problem.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: So I'm always
trying to find new places.
And one of the places-- you also
said you like the cold a lot.
So you must have a list of
places for five years and all
that, some non-standard
places, like Northern Quebec
is on my list.
Do you have stuff like
that on your list?
LISA GOREN: Well, the place
I'd really like to go right now
is Greenland.
Greenland is just beginning
to get on tourist's radars.
And part of it is
because of the melting.
And people want to see it.
But the glaciers in
Greenland are amazing.
I've flown over them
in the daylight.
And you can see the
glacier movement--
a glacier is a frozen river.
And so it's always moving.
And even though
it's small amounts--
so you can see the
motion from the plane.
I can't wait to go to Greenland.
But it's expensive.
All of these island places--
Iceland is expensive.
Places where they don't grow
a lot of their own food.
Alaska can be expensive.
But Greenland would
be my first place.
Iceland, anybody who
talks to me about Iceland,
that's an amazing place.
There's so much in Iceland.
There's lava.
There's hot springs.
But there's glaciers and
there's-- you can swim
in the water, the
hot waters as well.
And it's so close.
That's the other thing.
Iceland is a very
tourist-friendly place.
They all speak English.
After Greenland, I'd love
to go back to Antarctica.
But it's a really
long trip, you know.
That's the thing.
And expensive, also.
I've talked to
people about trying
to be an artist in
residence on a tour boat,
you know, something like that,
to kind of mitigate the cost.
And again, I don't
mind talking to people,
so I'm fine with that.
But that would be top
of the line there.
Yeah.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: I was just curious if
you had any big travel plans--
I guess you just got back--
but if you have any new travel
plans for--
it sounded like your kid was
going to move out of the house.
LISA GOREN: Yes.
Once he's gone,
that's when I can--
I've started applying for
grants to go to places
like Greenland and Iceland.
There are a lot of artists
residences on Iceland.
But they're mostly inland.
And I really want
to be on the shore.
But yeah, again, you know,
I'll start applying--
I could never go
back to Antarctica.
I went before he was born and
that is during the school year.
So unless you're in
Australia or something
where the school
year is different,
it would be impossible.
And like I said, it really
took a hit on the family.
I would say just
pulling him back
from what was a
really tough time--
I mean, to be honest,
it sucks to be
12, right, in a new school.
And then it's not helpful
if your parents are kind of
trying to figure out
what's going on for a month
during that time.
So, yes, once he's
gone, see you.
But people often ask me what
people wore or ate on the ship.
Does anybody want to know that?
I always get asked that.
The ship had to have
two weeks worth of food.
There was no place to stop.
And so we had these
huge freezers.
And the fresh fruit
was like really,
really-- they had been
refrigerated pears,
refrigerated apples,
stuff with that.
But we had a lot of
fish and a lot of stuff
that you could freeze.
In terms of clothing,
it was all the same
that what you would
wear in February here.
But the one thing
on this ship is
that because it was almost
all women in this group,
they did not buy
enough toilet paper.
So my roommate [? Nai-- ?] we're
both from the New York area--
we're not-- we were
like, we're taking it.
I don't care.
We put on our best New York
thug attitude, so to speak.
And we would sneak in
to the group bathroom
and steal rolls before--
and then we arrived at
this one store, the most
northernmost store, and they
bought a ton of toilet paper.
But it was like, the things that
they can't prepare for, you're
in trouble when you're on that.
So you were going
to have a question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Unrelated question,
though, if you wouldn't mind.
You were on a tall ship.
Did you sail?
LISA GOREN: We did.
We did.
It was a barquentine.
I don't know if that
means anything to you.
There were times when
we were under full sail.
But for much of the
time, it was combined.
But yes, we were
often used to help
pull the sails up, pull them
down, wrap them up, whatever.
There was a point
when we were sailing
and it was really rough.
And they said you
have to be below.
And we were like, OK.
And I don't particularly
get seasick,
so that was no problem.
There were people in
other rooms who were just
tossing their cookies.
But me and my
roommate were fine.
And we've just-- just
going like this, like this.
And I was so proud.
I was like, look at us
in the Arctic Ocean.
You know, because I'm
all like, Shackleton.
And we get out and I realize
we were in, like, a fjord.
It was nothing.
So I was like, oh, we
don't know anything.
It was rough.
But don't think we had any kind
of experience of that really
rough weather, although
in the Antarctic,
a storm was chasing us.
So as we went down, there
was a storm behind us.
You could only get
off the boat if it was
less than 35 knots, the wind.
And we got off the
boat every day,
two or three times every day.
The boat that was
behind us never got off.
They could never
get off the boat.
So you never know
what's going to happen
when you go to Antarctica.
But when we came back, we
went into the teeth of it.
And we got hit by
a rogue wave, which
stove the side of the boat in.
It wasn't a sailboat.
And I was in the cheap seats.
I was in the bottom
of the boat because I
couldn't afford more than that.
The people who had paid a lot
of money where they could have
like a balcony here,
so it was like this.
So this part doesn't
move as much.
So I didn't really know.
I didn't even feel it.
I was like, whatever.
And then we went up.
And I was like, oh my god.
The whole side of the
boat is, like, punched in.
And they had to change
course, because we
can't keep going into this.
They said, oh, yeah,
we'll fix it in a day.
Happens all the time.
And there was going to be
another tour group leaving--
like we get off on Saturday,
they leave on Sunday.
They said, oh yeah,
we'll be ready for that.
Yeah, it was-- they're used
to a very different scale
of those things.
AUDIENCE: Last
question, at night,
we have so much light here.
What were the stars like?
Was it amazing?
LISA GOREN: They were amazing.
It's cold at night.
When the sun is down,
it's really cold.
And so you have a lot of tears.
And I wear glasses.
So it's not as easy.
But I would say probably
one of the first times
I've ever seen the Milky Way.
I don't see that
in New York here.
I have no experience with it.
And so they were amazing,
but I couldn't see them
all the time that well.
We did see tiny bit
of northern lights,
but they were to the south
of us, just a little bit.
It's very hallucinogenic
in that kind of thing
where you just see this tiny
bit of green, and you're like,
is that real?
And you're tearing that
amount of time, too.
So it's like, what's real?
What am I imagining?
So kind of cool, but
also a little bit weird.
Anybody else?
Thank you so much
for listening to me.
[APPLAUSE]